okay what are we reviewing today
seriously this this is what we have to
review well okay let's get this over
with this is the twenty eighty super
review it's the card that literally
nobody cares about but we're gonna
review it anyway before that this video
is brought to you by us and the GN store
the best way to support our independent
reporting is through store gamers nexus
net this is made possible with your
purchases of merch like our GN medium
mod matte in stock and shipping now and
designed with GPU teardown diagrams and
grids our 100% custom-made two tone
shirt is also a great way to help and
it's currently on sale the shirt uses
95% cotton and 5% of lasting for a
sporty fit with vibrant colors and was
designed entirely by the GN team learn
more at the link in the description
below or go to store documents access
dotnet here's the problem with this card
it's completely fine it there's not
really any problems with it so then
that's the problem the problem is nvidia
is launching another 10 80 TI 1080 TI
version three now where you can
overclock a good 10 80 TI and more or
less get here or fall very very slightly
short of it and that's okay because it
has r TX i guess if you care about that
but the real problem is that there's
nothing exciting
AMD just launched everything and it was
like you know what just here you go
reviewers figure it out they have some
fun with Rison and navi and then maybe
next week you can get some sleep and
then end video was like you know what we
are going to launch another super card
we have no competition in this price
class except for our own cards and also
it doesn't add any new features there
are no new games with our TX to speak of
beyond what was different maybe two
weeks ago or three weeks ago there's no
new feature testing there is no new
anything so here's the summary of the
review the card is between 4 and 9
percent faster than a 2080
and that's really all you need to know
about it it's going to be $700 in theory
it has fifteen point five gigabit per
second memory instead of fourteen
gigabits per second
it's got 48 SMS instead of 46 so two
more are streaming multiprocessors and
therefore 128 more CUDA cores to 3072
from 29:44 the original clock of the non
efi 2080 was 1515 base 1710 boost and
this one is 1650 base 1815 boost and so
basically this card is barely worth our
time to even test the only reason we're
doing this is because there are
definitely people out there some of you
in the audience who genuinely want to
know however Forbes and that's
completely valid and we very much would
like to make sure you're not left in the
dark because this is it's it's fine like
there's nothing really it's not a bad
card it's just a phenomenally boring in
the middle of all of the hardware
launches like fourteen of them in the
last couple of one in the last ten days
or so and most of those are a lot more
exciting either because they're really
good they're really bad or they're just
different and all of those are good
reasons to push yourself to do reviews
and it's a points where you really don't
want to do them any more because this is
well I mean it just doesn't do it for us
but let's um let's just get it over with
and go through a couple of games five of
them should be enough to demonstrate the
scaling on this thing and then we'll
close it out we're going to start with
shadow of the Tomb Raider this time so
that we can demonstrate FPS improvements
scaling versus the twenty eighty across
three resolutions in this game the
twenty eighty super expanded its uplift
with each resolution uptick shadow the
Tomb Raider positions the twenty eighty
super where you'd expect and at 1080p
that's between the twenty atti on the
twenty eighty game in GPUs so about 142
FPS average to the 136 on the gigabyte
2018 on super the gain is about 4.5
percent over the twenty eighty 1440p has
the twenty eighty super at 101 FPS
average leading the twenty eighty gaming
by about five percent the twenty atti
maintains a lead of about nineteen
percent over the twenty eighty super
just for
reference at 4k the 20/80 super runs at
57 FPS average line at a lead of about
8.5% the only interesting thing here is
that we can learn how scaling improves
with resolution increases which
indicates something in the twenty eighty
super we think that something is
probably the faster memory being the
item to thank for the increased scaling
at higher resolutions on shadow of the
Tomb Raider Sniper Elite for used for
its dx12 nice Inc compute
implementations places the twenty eighty
super card at ninety one FPS average
with 4k benchmark that we run Sniper
Elite Four seems to like clocks on
Pascal and Toria architecture
demonstrated by the 1080 TI FCW three
pushed high out of the box twenty
seventy super overclocked
both of which outmatched the twenty
eighty original guards 82 FPS average
the twenty eighty super ends up at 90.5
of PS average benefiting from the higher
clocks which allow it a lead of about
ten percent had we tested a higher
Clark's twenty eighty it'd probably be
closer to the 1080i FCW three in this
one
everyone 2018 is next for DirectX 11 API
implementation at 1080p it has the
twenty eighty super at 177 FPS average
about a four percent lead over the
twenty eighty s at 170 FPS average
original score and roughly the same
improvement over in overclocked to
twenty seventy super 1440p testing has
the twenty eighty super at 139 FPS
average market at 4.8% ahead of the 2072
per with an overclocked at 133 FPS
average and similarly distanced from the
twenty eighty gaming original cart at 4k
the twenty eighty super ends up at
eighty-five FPS average versus the
twenty eighty s average FPS of eighty
which was previously outpaced by an
overclocked twenty seventy super and buy
a stock 1080 TI FTW three the total lead
is about six point five percent over the
gaming the twenty 80 gigabyte card
hitman two is next this time with just
DirectX 12 to save time because this
review is really predictable the twenty
eighty super place is at 136 FPS average
setting up between the potentially
cpu-bound twenty atti and the 131 FES
average of the twenty eighty which isn't
much ahead of the you 130 FPS average of
the 2071 overclocks the twenty seventy
super that is when overclocked
1440p with dx12 places the twenty eighty
super at 102 FPS average are about four
point seven percent ahead of the 98 FPS
average of the twenty eighty gaming sort
of boring really at 4k with dx12 hitman
two as the RT x 2080 super at fifty
p.s average leaning the 20/80 gaming by
6.3%
1080 TI tied the 2080 in this one so
it's also led by about six point three
percent if we had overclocked the 1080i
they'd be roughly equal far cry 5 is
next and last we'll start this one at 4k
at 4k for our high five places the 2080
super roughly tied with an overclocked
Radeon 7 which seems to do reasonably
well here actually the 2070 super
overclocked places at 61 FPS average
encroaching on the 2080 supers
performance for a few minutes of
overclocking work at 1440p it's the same
story the 2080 super ends up between the
20 atti 2080 gaming to no one's surprise
on the 2070 super again ties the 2080
Radeon 7 now it discontinued
demonstrates that it performs reasonably
well on at least one game and that it
had strong stock performance here okay
so the 2080 super it is a replacement
for the 2080 the 2080 is going away the
2070 super more or less beat the 2080
or was very close to it in most cases
the 2080 super is a amidst and not even
a mid step it's like a quarter step
towards the 2080 ti it's about the same
as a good overclocked like manually
overclock to 1080 Ti and it's $700 so
the price is relatively better than
where Nvidia was previously still for
our taste a bit high generationally and
Vidya has more or less taken its entire
stack and shifted it up so this probably
would have been called a 1080 TI in the
previous generation they've taken the TI
mark away they've given it to something
more expensive and so now the community
still feels like well on videos price
gouging in reality what NVIDIA has done
is taken all of the naming and shifted
it one step over because Nvidia realized
what mr. David Cantor who's been on our
channel has realized for a long time now
which is that Nvidia could charge a lot
more for it stuff and so they did and
David you shouldn't have published that
because they listened to you so yeah I'm
not really sure what to say other than
it's acceptable there's no competition
at the price class except for other
Nvidia stuff and we're not really sure
who to blame for that you could
partially blame AMD
and say AMD what the heck get into gear
do something you're just continuing
Radeon 7 1 who bought it feels
probably the same buyer's remorse that
people talk about with these super cards
for NVIDIA buyers because it came out
what six months ago and now 5700 XD
equals its performance in like at least
70 to 80% of the titles we've tested so
far cry 5 maybe notwithstanding so Andy
please do something to make these
reviews worth our time again and NVIDIA
in the future maybe launch some kind of
feature with it a tech demo aligned with
games that use your your r-tx hardware
and software development literally
anything anything that makes saying it's
4 to 9 percent faster more interesting
than saying it's 4 to 9 percent faster
this review was done in the first two
minutes of the review when I said it's
four to nine percent faster that's all
you need to know about this video card
that and it's $700 so if you watch this
far I am sorry that we've wasted your
time
you can blame Nvidia and otherwise the
card itself is acceptable it's fine it's
uninteresting and that's really all
there is to it that doesn't mean it's
bad to buy it doesn't mean it's not
worth buying
it means it's barely worth reviewing
though so anyway thanks for watching
subscribe for more hopefully better
content that's more interesting than
this you can go to patreon.com/scishow
sexist to help side directly or stored
on camera sexist net to pick up a
teardown toolkit which we will not be
using on this video card because there's
no point because it's boring and I'll
see you all next time
[Music]